one more creepy viral tick-tock video
uh these sex scandals seem very strange
today
because we've all gotten used to all
sorts of sexual scandals that aren't
even scandalous anymore there was a tick
tock that went viral
of some person on the left describing
regular old heterosexuality you know
just a man and a woman love each other
very much
and have babies as a breeding kink
oh i'm super straight i'm only attracted
to women who can bear me children
babe that's called a breeding kink
and it's not a sexuality so a breeding
kink
is this individual is making fun of
people who
hold a traditional sexual ethic who
think that
in the words of the great philosopher
nor macdonald sex is a filthy shameful
thing that obviously is only meant for
procreation
and that you should maybe get married
before you have sex and that when you
have sex you should be open to the
possibility of life and have children
and have a really good life
and what this person is saying is no
that's a breeding kink
some people have a kink for whips and
chains
some people have a kink for threesomes
and
some people have a kink for breeding but
it's all just kinks right it's all just
kind of weird
quirks of sex and
what that implies is that there's no
standard what that implies is that
that no sort of sexual behavior is any
better or worse than any other sort of
sexual behavior
right it's all just relative it's all
just what you want it's all about your
desires now this creates a problem in
the metoo era
because their sexual standards will come
in
they will be enforced in some way and so
now people have to explain
why certain sort of
ugly sexual encounters are fine but the
exact same
sorts of sexual encounters when they're
undertaken by different people or in
different circumstances are not fine
and it's just it's very very confusing
we've been told that women are totally
liberated they ought to be able to
relate to sex in exactly the same way as
men but then when women come to regret
sex
as in the case of high profile cases
like marilyn manson or other
other uh uh partners and
lovers of these these various men they
say well yes it was consensual but he
still abused me and i didn't like it men
and women are different but they're not
different and
it's all very confusing because we don't
have
any sort of standard i'm glad you liked
that clip i hope
that you will listen to the entire show
head on over to apple podcast or spotify
or stitcher or wherever you get your
podcasts
subscribe to the michael knowles show
the episode is called destruction for us
disco for the elites we'll see you next
time
[Music]
[Music]